bro girls do that in like fitting rooms
like when Tiff used to work at retail
all the time they would just find used
tampons just in the fitting room why
could turn a man gay I don't know bro
why don't they carry a PL like a Ziploc
bag and put it in there and take it home
I dare you to suggest that to an actual
woman people are just weird
[Music]
man so imagine you're at a Dunkin Donuts
as people are oh oh Duncan Donuts is
fire dude I like I like Duncan I love
American establish can we get donuts
tomor there's also worldwide you get
right
now that's the energy we that's a
business owner by the way a man with
vision that's an entrepreneur baby a get
it D kind
of so imagine you're you're at a Duncan
and you're in line and you're like a man
I got to use this right oh no and then
you go in into the bathroom right and
you You' sit down you pull down your
pants and then you're in the middle of
doing your business and then the toilet
under you explodes
no like blows up the toilet underneath
your butt explodes big time is it after
you cuz like you and then the article
doesn't say but what I know is that this
man emerged from the public restroom in
the Duncan covered in oh no covered in
it oh no covered in human feces you
saying he was dunked in it he got dunked
in definitely like like a donut into the
coffee how did that happen so um that's
crazy there was a gas leak here's the
story his name is Paul kowak not Jack
first and last name associated his name
is Paul carak and you to remember that
and if you see this guy in public make
sure that you remember you call him you
call him
the yeah hey you're the boy aren you man
boy bet you're a little traumatized huh
Bud hey bud oh you go to the bathroom
later maybe I should Duck and Cover her
up he sh so hard he blew up the toilet
he blew up the toilet dude that he
literally because he sh so hard well we
don't know it's because he [__] so hard
it says in the article he was playing
with cherry bombs dude and he was like I
don't know what happened I didn't they P
their PC it's cuz he pooped so hard
yeah whack they're real PC no so this
guy seeking more than $100,000 in a
lawsuit filed in Orlando claiming he
suffered
[Music]
hemorrhoids severe long-term injuries
following the explosion of a toilet in
the men's room of a Duncan bro that's
crazy did the toilet blow up the toilet
blew up hey you know when you're just
sitting and chilling like when you're
about to get hit in the face and you get
brace for impact like the the impact
doesn't what's the defense as a
Jiu-Jitsu Bast what's the defense ass
explosion yeah but your ass isn't ready
for it and you can't your holes open in
guard you got to get in guard my boy
dude my boy is sitting on the toilet and
he's probably just scrolling away dude
Fe up on the toil sometimes [__]
sometimes was just like a fire and he
just explodes was it like a fire based
explosion or like an like a water
pressure base to the water pressure
might be worse do I look like a [__]
fireman D the last air bender over there
dude if he was covered in [__] that
means the poop flew back up he was
covered in urine and Fe oh God debris
too by the way what if they measure the
percentage of that is your own so then
the settlement's lower they're like
we're going to take 15% off of it
because that's your own your own [__]
yeah like imagine if a pipe burst and it
just shot up in you that's imagine he
walks out the bathroom and he's cover
this stuff and he's like but it doesn't
smell
that I thought it' smell worse it's his
own Supply he's like this smell that ass
but everybody still smelling his [__]
like everyone else is like what the oh
my God oh my he's like he's it doesn't
smell that bad he's waving it on people
like check it out check it out he's not
suing Duncan right is it a Duncan oh
yeah against Duncan he's still a Duncan
oh dude you got to who's who else cuz he
got dunked on when he's D then honestly
100 low low key $100,000 seems manable
for dunk donut that's a very low just as
much as $100,000 seems reasonable to be
covered in [__] for like a short period
of time I think this is real damage the
emotional the emotional distress has to
be [__] through the roof his [__]
blown out he's giving them a break if
everybody catches wi of the super viral
JK vide is about to go out with his
first and last name calling him [__] boy
for the next two years though that's
just win by the way yeah the fact that
seems like if you see him call him [__]
Boy [__]
boy how you the [__] boy I think dck
should pay him more because we're just
we're just accessories to the story
we're not we're not the ones that should
be this is not our responsibility right
I'm just saying that's emotional damage
times that's a low number damage he
could have get a mill give him a mill
bro at least dude come on in this
economy maybe 300 Grand maybe 300 what
you do when as soon as this guy comes in
the room you start
going anybody could dunk in any donuts
here smells like hm nah it can't be
there's no way it's a bird it's a plane
it's [__] boy no there's no way [__] boy
here there's no way we have to oh no no
way it's chip boys here I heard that was
a Ducket in Kansas it
Cy was ducking how far are we from
Orlando
anyway uh so yeah he Mr remember his
name again Paul
carak Paul carak walked out of the uh
[__] covered in humanid feces urine
and debris he walked out of the he
deserves the money Duncan this is maybe
my favorite
part he walked out of the men's room
seeking help no shut up shut up does
anyone have a
now he's like seeking look he walked out
of the men's room seeking help shut the
[__] real seeking help yeah seeing help
from workers so boom you open the door
like help me imagine that [__] on your
face oh my God you know what I would
have done I would have been like stay
there I would have pulled the hose and
just sprayed the [__] down you
know some other like customer saw that
dude and just left they ran they ran
what would you do Nick or you're they're
already in line and they're like I'm
waiting for my [__] I'm getting my
[__] Nick what would you do what
would you do if I was if I if I was
waiting in line a [__] covered swamp
thing comes out of the this is how I
imagine it happened right I'm waiting a
line and I'm like should I get the
[__]
oldfashioned should I get the other one
you hear a loud bang for the bathroom
yeah and then you see this guy walking
out like waddling out he's asking for
help and he's looking right at you I'm
carow just say his name guys Paul as a
man you're never in a more vulnerable
state than when you're [__] you're
looking at me I'm going to be pants
around the ankles and all I'm going to
be like this I'm my
go [__] should I get the the bacon ched
are you going to get the chocolate
covered my name is my name is but Paul
car I'm from I'm from Orlando Florida I
need help please you guys still have the
pumpkin spice please oh God please I'm
covered my own [__] in Ur please Nick
please sir please don't you if I'm Paul
I'm going to be like please take a photo
of this moment please take a video and
document where I am and get Dunkin
Donut's name in here you get a bunch of
brown napkins you give it to the [__] by
the way if you really want to narrow it
down his attorney's name is Scott
Spradley all right now Scott Scott has
been tied up he can't take a lot of
questions just so you know but that's
his name and uh yeah so the lawsuit says
that Mr kowak Right he suffered bodily
injury he's required mental health care
and counseling since the incident that's
crazy I didn't know kak was spelled k e
r o u a c oh yeah for real actually I
would have spelled it way different C
right cuz you never read a [__] book
never read on the road you [__]
uncultured swine what the [__] is on the
jack carak on the road you guys look I
know I'm like the white savior but like
I can't Ed I can't be also your educator
okay you know this kind of music no
what's the what's the defense okay let's
say now you're playing the role of
Duncan you're being sued and let's say
you need a defense against this
situation oh easy easy your honor this
is a coffee shop People come in here and
they take crazy crazy shits all the time
this is just part of the business this
is just part of the business okay you
come in here you eat shits like you eat
a bunch of coffee you eat [__] sorry
excuse me sorry you're take a donut you
eat some [__] you're fired you're fired
Nick no Honestly though I was thinking
about this cuz I used to work I used to
study in coffee shops exclusively all
throughout College all the time and it's
always exploding in there dude the
bathrooms or every coffee shop you go to
it's the amount of explosive diarrhea
you see on the on the porcelain walls
it's insane disgusting but you know it's
always it's part of the game it's part
of the nature that's why it's it's so
sad that you know you want a restaurant
you want to like coffee shop yeah but
you have a dream but then you always
have to wonder do you want to provide
rooms for the customers hey coffee's a
diuretic though specific cuz you know
there's going to be diarrhea from the
wall all the way down to the seat one of
my buddies who owns a coffee shop would
tell me that there was a guy who would
come in all the time and he would do
anas in his bathroom
why God damn cuz you know there's some
guys that they hang out in the coffee
shop all day and all they do is just
chill bro and he would do enemas in the
bathroom oh it cuz it's a coffee enema
but that's not that crazy cuz Bart has
crazy stories about people just coming
to barbell just to take [__] we uh
someone took a [__] in the trash can why
what the hell which trash can in the in
the bathroom he's like it's in the
bathroom people are just weird oh in the
bathroom is a whole other level that's
[__] up just people are just weird why
don't they used the toilet somebody was
trying to come after bar I don't know
this is like I don't know like [__] you
think it's like [__] 24-Hour Fitness
down the street you know what I mean I
don't know people are just weird in I
heard Fitness is territorial know worse
than finding [__] in your bathroom like
that cuz when I had the studios we it
was like mainly a lot of girls a lot of
models the amount of times that there
was a soiled tampon yeah within nose
range that is a smell Jesus that has to
be from [__] hads but from where like
they just is just in the corner it's
just in the top of the trash or in the
toilet not flushed bro girls do that in
like fitting rooms like when Tiff used
to work at retail all the time they
would just find used tampons just in the
fitting room why could turn a man gay I
don't know bro why don't they carry a PL
like a Ziploc bag and put it in there
and take it home I dare you to suggest
that to an actual woman people are just
weird man they're just weirdos out there
literally I think that's the equivalent
of like a guy [__] in a trash can
it's like a woman it's like why would
you do that people are just [__] weak
so you don't believe the toilet really
blew up I believe the the toilet it blew
up cuz Paul carak was covered of Orlando
California what's the CCTV look like is
like i' counter suit I'd be like he has
lethal we like amounts of methane in his
ass what could make the toilet Paul
carak is a history of [__] and
blowing up toilets that's what you
say if I'm doing the insurance claim I
hire a pi we follow him to Carl's Jr and
[__] and we set up
Cherry you know what else you do as a
lawyer you you say hey we need the state
to get feal testing from Paul [__]
carow that's what you do and then you
you put his uh you put his stuff through
a gut biome test and you're like yeah
dude this guy he's all over the place I
feel like the way easier thing to do is
be like he's asking for 100 100,000
that's it give him 110 and make him sign
the say he can't talk about it ever
again I'm too oh it's too late though
right we have to make an example because
a JK is just Paul carak is a [__]
liar he's a [__] covered liar [__]
covered and urine covered liar they call
him [__] boy for a reason come on ship
your ship dun's words Duncan's words not
ours we're just we're the news what
makes the toilet
explode uh coffee shits and I do free
donuts for
[Music]
life